“CANCER”.... doesn’t the term scare
us all?
Well it surely does!
But how does this
bizarre disorder grip our lives?
How is it able to conquer over our mind, body
and
soul?
Why is it so scary?
Let us find the answers in this video!
We will start by understanding what exactly
cancer is.
We all know that the cells in our body continuously
divide.
Cell Division occurs for
various reasons ranging from growth and development
to repair.
However, the process happens in an orderly
manner.
Now if the cells lose control
over their division process, then the uncontrolled
division can lead to formation
of lumps of outrageous cells.
This is nothing but Cancer!
In simple words, Cancer is a disorder which
develops when the cells in our body
grow out of control, creating a cell mass.
This mass of cells known as tumor.
Now tell me, is every tumor growing in the
body always cancerous?
Many of us
would yes….
But the answer is a No!
Every tumor is not cancerous.
A tumor is a mass or lump of cells.
So depending
upon whether it is capable of invading other
tissues and cause harm, or it can
silently remain at one place without harming
other cells in the vicinity, a tumor is
classified in two major types.
One type is called malignant and the other
type is
called benign.
Let’s understand each type one by one.
Sometimes, a few cells lose their ability
of controlled division and form a tumor.
But after a particular time, the tumor does
not grow much in size and remains
calm at its place.
It does not spread across the blood to invade
surrounding
tissues.
These calm, harmless and non-cancerous tumors
are called Benign
tumors.
On the other hand, malignant tumors are cancerous.
They spread and invade
other body tissues.
Here, their aggressive nature helps the tumor
cells to derive
nutrients from other surrounding healthy cells.
As a result, the healthy cells die
and this gives the tumor cells an opportunity
to grow even faster!
The process of spreading of the cancer cells
to other body parts, and then growing
continuously in those locations is known as
metastasis.
Now that we have learned about the types of
tumors, let’s move ahead and learn
about the types of cancer.
Are there types of cancers?
Yes there are!
Among the
several types of cancers studied today, we
will mainly focus on three major types.
On our list we have carcinomas, sarcomas,
leukemias and lymphomas.
Let us glance at these types.
Carcinomas are cancers of epithelial tissues.
That means, carcinomas are
developed in the skin and tissue lining of
the organs like prostate, breast, colon,
pancreas, lungs and so on.
The next type is that of Sarcomas.
These types arise in the connective tissues
like
bone cells, cartilage, muscles and other soft
tissues in the body.
Now talking about Lymphomas and Leukemias,
aren&#39;t the names self-
explanatory?
Lymphomas, as the name suggests, are the cancers
that develop in
the lymphocytes, which are a type of white
blood cells.
On the other hand,
cancers which result in an abnormal amount
of blood cells like abnormal number
of red blood cells, or leukocytes are known
as leukemias.
So both, lymphocytes
and leukemias are types of blood cancers!
And how is any of these types detected?
There are several techniques developed today,
all thanks to the modern science
and technology.
For diagnosis various tests are performed
on the patients.
Imaging techniques like
x-ray, computer tomography, magnetic resonance
imaging, PET CT scan and many
more are performed.
These imaging techniques give the medical
examiner an idea
of the size, shape and location of a particular
tumor or multiple tumors inside the
body.
Similarly, Blood tests can be done to find
out the different types of blood cancers.
Biopsies of the tissues are also done for
better diagnosis.
That is, a small sample
of tissue or the tumor to be precise, is removed
from the patient&#39;s body to
determine the nature of cancer.
Oncologists, that is medical practitioners
dealing with cancers, believe that early
diagnosis of any type of cancer gives a better
chance of curing the case and this
increases the survival rate in cancer patients.
The most common treatments for cancer include
surgery, chemotherapy and
radiotherapy.
Surgeries are performed to remove the tumor
from the body.
In chemotherapy
various drugs which inhibit the growth of
growing cells in the body are used.
Since these drugs kill the growing cells,
all the aggressively growing cancer cells
get killed with different doses.
Lastly, radiotherapy focuses on destroying
tumor cells using different radiations.
High doses of radiation are used to kill or
shrink tumor cells.
Apart from these, there are various other
techniques which are being developed
and are under trial stages in clinical testing.
A healthy lifestyle, and avoiding exposure
to harmful chemicals and radiation are
a few steps to keep our body cells from getting
damaged, and turn aggressive!
Also, regular health checkups which can help
in early detection of any type of
tumor, can increase the chances of curing
the patient!
This was about one of the most dangerous disorders
that the human race is
fighting today!
To know about more interesting concepts, do
subscribe to our channel!
Happy learning!!